hello and welcome this video playing
Joker n or joel coen might be you hon
the scan or something like that ok so
cut the row here go for the brayer which
I still have not studied in detail but
let's see how we fare without the study
my experience is that you can still get
fairly decent positions of you have some
experience with the general position
type and have played quite a bit of
those closed Spanish asst over the years
now very early night h2 does he want to
go F for in this position don't really
believe it not with my bishops both
fianchetto okay um I'm still not badly
equipped for four years but I won't take
this opportunity to play C form okay I'm
taking
hmm
adds an interesting decision playing
with this pawn structure here the H file
hmm i think teague with the Bishop
Bishop is of course terrible on a eight
but i probably need the Queen under on
the King side for defense yes so I think
f6 I have to get rid of that porn
it's just far too annoying in the long
run and Bishop g5 is a the trade that I
don't mind
I had the only problem is my bishop that
okay thats So Ji jiggly almost suicidal
they just you know as to check made me
here Quinn g5g five I guess we have
three 9797 495 it's it's it's
strategically on a very risky decision
because bishop on c2 is bad night on g3
is bad I get a fantastic night on e5 and
almost any endgame is winning there's a
check on c1 jack so night between here
now chan 95 should it should lose
material really not just being
strategically bad
so we asked kept this material but you
cannot really do that much so look f-84f
to maybe so feels like I had something
something better
can take playbook f to Bishop d1 or
queen g 5 25 years good asking this
regret is supposed to go and then night
you for look a tree looks like the only
move I probably handing this really bad
lame and missing more more decisive
continuations rook f2
check okay but it's good enough white
resigns yeah that F fumbles that that
doesn't that doesn't seem right here we
still have a fairly normal on Rue La Paz
position yeah I'm g5 okay yeah that
shouldn't harm white I think but for I
think it did this lose us it should lose
the game it's it's two jejeje so
committal the engine does not agree does
not agree interestingly enough first of
all it wants to take with the bishop
because here there was cringy form
that's a move I didn't see at all and I
also don't see what the point is to be
honest can I wanna just go here yeah
this is interesting why isn't the
computer giving this as good for black
maybe because my bishop takes so long to
get them to get back into the game and
the night will come to deform yeah maybe
it's just just about it just about is ok
because the b5 point is also big it
might be
yeah if wide regroups this the computer
still thinks wide is okay it's pretty
remarkable but ok I take three moves to
get this back into the game
still have a hard time to accept that
this should be equal for one with this
bed with the bed structure but ok this
is really weak and that I mean it's not
yeah it's not so weak but at a this
takes a long time gather computer give
something like this and now 96 until you
have to take a and this is not nothing
special this is very active here it's
probably equal really is only only this
is then she has a real issue j ok thats
it's a thermograph to as a nice one chad
this isn't this isn't worse ya hear this
has nothing that that white can do i can
attack take him check and win the queen
so that's interesting I really thought
f4 would be pretty terrible but it's
remarkable that white has this
compensation with 92 to d4 because of my
totally misplaced bishop interesting ok
thanks for watching